aloha people we're here today we're
gonna watch brooklyn nine-nine episode
15 of the first season only seven or
eight more to go i forget how many are
in the final count guys hit that like
button if you end up enjoying our
reaction subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction is up full length
watch logs over at our patreon page
cover a bunch of shows over there as
well
lastly thank you for tha more jaden and
i you got to tell me in advance which
one of you is editing but i appreciate
it let's get into it
we've busted murderers we've taken down
cartels but today we face the worst new
york has to offer
the fire department
they back
no
classic terry cruz dance moves
classic terry crews football skills
[Laughter]
healthy breakfast are those gummy bears
wrapped in a fruit roll-up
breakfast burrito oh yeah i pity your
dentist ugh
oh those pearlies say otherwise vision
just called they're taking over your
murder case the vulture is on his way
here now two recurring characters what
you took one for me and rosa last week
it's over
thanks guys
commence operation broken feather and go
i need your full signed confession we
have four minutes we can do this but i'm
not guilty listen to me gus
we can do this
oh god police station or a toilet
because all i see is turds
attack the pembroke
[Music]
good first plan lucky for you this wipes
off quickly this coast made out of whale
skin
what do you say we go talk about a case
in the break room oh yeah what case is
that a case of how you got so damn sexy
god owed me a favor
okay so
come on we only have three minutes it's
like you're not even trying to confess
[Laughter]
come on buddy do something i got it your
gap
he loves to take his shirt off guys is
the
[Laughter]
i phoenix it from here
all right fine
i'll just go then with this fully signed
confession we did it gus
i killed that guy and his neighbor but
you were too late
wait you killed his neighbor
got it framed of course it commemorates
our victory over the vulture look at her
hair i know
all rise
manager at the prentice hotel told us
that someone's been breaking into the
room stolen over a hundred thousand
dollars in jewelry i'm a little ocd
what no you're not
i can leave it there totally
it doesn't bother me i know
that'd make anyone uncomfortable
our comstat numbers are due tomorrow
morning so i need these arrests on the
books today i had a belly dancing class
tonight was egyptian undulation oh show
us some moves sure
yeah
well i wanted to see the moves the cops
had numbers are due tomorrow at 9 a.m
but at this rate we won't be finished
until your daughters are grown and
married
i have been taking notes oh no the red
areas are places where no work gets done
if we can fix these problems without
anyone knowing what we're doing we will
finish on time
sounds fine let's do it
sounds fun
i might get a promotion of major crimes
they asked me to come in an interview
for a job no you're gonna go work for
the vulture have you forgotten how awful
he is
70 bucks a pair and the only increase in
value
backstabber i'm surprised you read
othello what the hell's othello i'm
calling you the parrot from aladdin
here's the plan we're gonna catch this
perp you're gonna remember how much you
love your job you're gonna skip that
interview and that's a peralta guarantee
your last pearl to guarantee was that
you could dunk a basketball i never said
i couldn't use a ladder peralta
guarantee achieved
good what's this red area here the diaz
drangle right so you know about rose's
anger incident it's my birthday if you
wish me a happy birthday i will punch
you happy birthday oh
everyone in the squad avoids it
mountains humorous yes
[Laughter]
the bathroom
if people are afraid to walk ideas
bathroom breaks will be to a minimum
[Laughter]
some bad checks but is this the same guy
yeah the name here is the same name
okay all right thank you
come on i'm so sick of these sucky
computers
[Applause]
one more step in your next
job well done
what is this music
oh this is from my country near
krakagovia do you like it i weirdly do
why do you even care if i leave
that whole division is the worst they
steal cases it's
sure
aha the jacket
this case is heating up ooh receipt in
the pocket dust it for prints and send a
scan to boil yes you're feeling it now
oh
he's surprisingly photogenic a lot of
criminals are strangely he doesn't work
here must have stolen the bellhop
uniform
receptionist just bought it to santo
entering the salieri ballroom what's
going on in there an auction of greek
antiquities ah i believe it's pronounced
antiques
tell me about the boyle lynnetti
reaction boyle gets cold a lot because
of what he calls his medically diagnosed
thin skin
[Laughter]
that's when gina gets involved
sweet sweater charles look like you're
starring in an albanian remake of the
cosby show dr hexable
dr hextoball
gina is completely useless when boyle is
wearing lost and found quotes maybe we
should just uh empty lost and bound
already done sir detective yeah right
good
no no
oh my god we're doomed
boyle looks like a lesbian
i had a backup plan i distracted her
with a mirror
i distracted her with a mirror
hello sexy how are you right back at you
[Laughter]
harmony i'm detective peralta this is
detective always stays loyal she's named
after her father alvin stays
loyal anyone can get up on stage by the
podium you'll blow our cover if you go
up there you don't exactly blend in yeah
no no
how would you like to have the honor of
being the first man to undress in front
of amy
santiago hello everyone my name is roger
strikewell and i will be your guest
auctioneer this evening and i'm so
excited to be here tonight to sell you
all of these cool old greek things
it is this
old vase above if you're nasty it was
made in the year
five
and depicts the classic greek fable boy
meets girl
and on the back
just a whole bunch of
wheat bidding at ten dollars
if we stay on this pace i think we'll
finish on time i think we should keep
going make the office even more
efficient oh god oh god familiar with
the story of icarus he didn't know when
to quit
he flew too close to the sun and his wax
wings melted and he died are you
familiar with the story of moneyball
uses statistics and logic to win several
baseball games it's my favorite film the
statistical analysis
it's so beautiful
i'm flying by sergeant
and i'm never
coming down
what have you created terry i have 90
from the man with the face at table 4.
this is terrible
you don't know what you're doing oh
i'm writing a movie right now about the
russian revolution oh really who does
kevin james play in it uh-huh it's a
serious movie trotsky ah
i think you could use it for a variety
of things new item up there whoa
stick my socks in this moron's mouth i
will did football legend joe theismann
just bit a thousand dollars to put a
sock in my mouth you bet
can i stick the sock in his mouth i'll
pay extra yes you may because i just
sold my item to the man in the great
shirt at table 18. nypd you're under
arrest
oh no no get him
nice
no
my leg you broke my other leg
my leg jake i'm still doing the
interview what no
don't do that
you're being a bad partner
you're joining forces with the enemy and
from now on i'm gonna call you the
cheetah
you're my only friend now
the captain put me here says i waste
time when i sit next to hitchcock
santiago wants to make captain one day i
know because i frequently caught her
wearing my hat and looking into a mirror
that's what good detectives do they have
each other's back no matter what
fire oh my fire uh hey here we go
what happened scully i didn't know there
was a toaster there why is the toaster
there
oh
back to the drawing board sir i'm
begging you please we have to stop
surrendering
in our next trial
um
gina what are you doing in the captain's
chair please i'm open to any ideas about
efficiency
the holt jeffords vortex things would go
a lot faster if the two of you did less
experimenting and more working and i'm
not the only one who thinks that
[Music]
you melted my fringe
sorry i said you were a bad partner i
was the bad partner
the truth is our job isn't always great
i mean sometimes it sucks but
it sucks a little less when i get to do
with you
um you're a great detective and they'd
be lucky to have you letter of
recommendation
which is riddled with spelling errors i
might add including the word
recommendation which is just i don't
have to tell you about that there's no
way there's four m's in that one i
already
kiss him i don't want to sit at a desk
and right now
i like where i am hmm but thanks for
thinking i'm great no i take back all
the things i just said uh-uh you said i
was a good detective and you were
nice
cookie lookie
i thought i saw your big white ass
lumbering around
all right everybody just calm down
there's no reason we can't be friends
here i brought you a peace offering
oh
jeez
nice
it's good we gotta get some of those
what's up guys
we're shooting brooklyn nine-nine
and then the power went out
so we're gonna use old-fashioned
sunlight look there's the fan
it's still going kinda
yeah hey guys so we're in the middle of
our review
halfway through it
and then uh the power went out
and so it's been out for about an hour
100 degrees now we're solar powered and
burning inside so we're like screw it
let's just get on our phone because a
bit of a time crunch here won't have
time to continue through tomorrow got to
get this footage squared away tonight so
anyway
um yeah this was uh john
you might hear kids outside in the pool
those kids who you you hear
when we're doing normal videos it would
even be louder now yeah
i thought this was really funny i
thought this was a hilarious episode not
gonna say the exact words i usually say
but yeah both plot lines across this i
thought made for really great both you
know
broad comedy but also character beats i
love the back and forth between
peralta and santiago and just what's you
know growing there it's it's a classic
dynamic but i feel like the way that
they're growing it gradually is a lot of
fun to watch as well having the opposite
side of you know the two dudes in charge
you got terry and
captain holt trying to figure out like i
love the whole breakdown of like here's
how the office functions and where the
efficiencies falter and and them like
trying to crack the whole thing like i
don't know i thought that meant for just
like a really hilarious uh you know
dueling like two very different plot
lines with two really funny plot lines
together in the same package so
that is very true
good analysis john thanks what happened
in this episode
well you know it's been an hour they
started playing uh football against the
fire department oh yeah they played
football just to get pattern oswald back
doesn't factor into the story i thought
we might get a little bit of a crossover
here with the vulture and pattern oswalt
and they brought back they brought back
more lymph nodes
original review where i couldn't
remember his name for the longest time
but now you know now it's going to be
efficient as hell
fred armisen bringing him back adam
sandler showing up in here was a ton of
fun
um
i wonder when this came out because i i
did see the movie they were in called
that's my boy which i thought was pretty
funny i know adam sounded movies got a
lot of crap
but i actually think that's my boy is
one of his better ones it's uh it's a
really
crude hard r funny movie and i think him
and andy i think adam's adam sandler and
andy sandberg actually have really good
chemistry together in that film uh i
know that's not a popular opinion but i
really enjoy the hell out of that so
it's fun seeing him pop up in here
and yeah you know like freaking amy
santiago and and peralta they have just
such good chemistry together like it's
just so
so much of the time you're like i just
want you guys to kiss already i don't
even care just do it make out go for it
doesn't matter if this is the right time
or not
yeah you might as well go for it
but i i really i really enjoy their
chemistry a lot and you know peralta
having to learn
about
learning how to support in spite of his
own ego and his own selfish desires he's
probably he's not even being truthful to
himself about what he really wants and
why he really wants amy to stay
i think he's great it's like he keeps
that childish part of his character
alive
and as one narcissist to another i
really appreciate it i really do like it
seeing that on display here
and uh what else happened oh the
statistical analysis thing i don't think
uh nothing holding anything wrong
efficiency should be kept going should
have kept going he was right about that
moneyball comparison how else do you
keep things going successfully if you
can't run efficiently look at us now yes
we could just wait around wait hour it
could be hours for the power's back on
recording everything i was reading
online but we got battery hours and [ __ ]
that we can use to maintain exactly
efficiency you gotta be efficient yeah
gotta keep it going even if the video
quality and audio quality suffers most
people don't make it as far in the video
don't they click off before the
reactions
yeah they click off so it's like
you know for those who made it this far
just know holt was right
it was a really funny bit though
i do like seeing them take advantage of
the employees that way yes and then just
like to have a staff and work that way
oh yeah i'm sure you could break it down
like that i couldn't see your chart in
my mind's eye
and only you would be able to decipher
the chart because of your handwriting
that's true yeah it sounds
a mystery as to how to tap it unless
you're reading it i can't read my own
handwriting there's plenty of times i'm
like what did i say
it's good though that's good though that
you'll never get caught on a handwriting
you know match
maybe we should do all reviews like this
there you know it's relaxed it's nice
out here it's like hey everybody step
out on the balcony with us and let's
just chat about brooklyn ryan let's just
come out here
chit chat after that
awesome episode of television crack a
couple beers and then just sit here for
the end of the review for like 10
minutes and not even talk you know it
was nice to see them beat the vulture it
was like cameo the episode i know so
many cameos i know
all independent of one
yeah which is funny because yeah it's
like it feels like you're not
not adam sandler and uh and joe joe's
been yeah yeah oh that's true though
that we did get a double center p that's
that's five cameos there's a lot of
cameos yeah which is funny guy i'm like
was this released at a moment in time
where they were gonna take a little
break or something like that like it
seems like a momentous occasion to have
five cameos and yet they somehow and
it's not a gripe but they do feel sort
of incidental or just like oh here's a
bit you know like the most uh uh engaged
one is obviously having the vulture
around just because of the threat i'm
like oh amy's gonna go work with him but
uh i still really enjoyed his presence i
still thought he was funny and that
whole
bit where he they're getting the guy to
confess that the dude is like by the end
of it
for showing up the vulture like those
those bits especially really worked on
me this episode they hide in the sketch
comedy element to this one a lot
they just throw adam sandler in there to
not feel lived in at all
just to beat him
straight out of an adam sandler comedy
movie yeah
it's like on vacation at an auction
messing around being his laid-back self
well it literally felt like he popped
into the episode he was like oh you guys
are filming i just let me jump in and
improvise
like they're talking over each other and
i'm like i bet you didn't even have a
script
solid stuff mm-hmm i think we had more
to say i can't really remember it right
now you know i mean it's probably better
this way it's probably more efficient i
mean the length of our review is roughly
one-third the length of the episode
that's true that's true that's a good
statistic but we can we can stretch this
out man you know what i noticed this
episode is that there was at least one
moment where scully
you know so i mean not even one moment
he got productive this episode was crazy
well i i really like that holt was wrong
and he had to confront the whole staff
about it yes because he's usually the
mentor who knows all yeah
but i i really like the moment he has to
confront everybody where he's being told
he's wrong the whole time and of course
gina is the one who uses like guys you
two now yeah are the suction of
efficiency yeah that's that's kind of
clever like the thing that's hindering
it the most is that they're not being
productive yeah they're just obsessing
over this yeah
it's a nice revelation of events
oh yeah all right guys well
thank you so much for being here
listen
if you want
to tell me the name of an assassin
i'd be more than happy
to uh
conduct an email to him or her
because there's some people that need to
be taken out
first no water this week
then the water's back on but no hot
water
water comes on
now no power
children at the pool the pandemic is
very much alive
it's now it's starting to affect all the
technologies
thank you guys for being here i'll see
you soon
[Music]